[Música]
sabíais que hay un país en sudamérica
donde la mayor parte de la población es
de origen indio y el inglés es el idioma
oficial
[Música]
si no sabéis a qué país me estoy
refiriendo no te preocupes porque este
es uno de los países más desconocidos de
toda la región y la verdad para ser
justos no es habitual que los medios de
comunicación se refieran siquiera el
país pequeño poco conocido los medios no
hablan de él exacto los ingredientes
perfectos para un vídeo de visual
política
[Música]
hablamos de guyana una antigua colonia
británica que no obtuvo su independencia
hasta 1966 por cierto en ese momento
tanto el gobierno como el estado de
ánimo general apostaban por convertir el
país en un estado socialista y
precisamente de ese deseo proviene su
curioso nombre oficial la república
cooperativa de guyana pero no nos
desviemos guyana es uno de los países
más pobres y con mayores tasas de
criminalidad y violencia de toda
sudamérica y claro dada las
circunstancias eso es mucho decir de
hecho amigos la situación es tan
desalentadora que si este país es
conocido por algo es por ser una
referencia en la distribución
internacional de cocaína y por tener
cuidado la mayor tasa de suicidios del
mundo con estos datos no parece que
podamos ser muy optimistas con el futuro
de este país verdad sin embargo su
suerte está a punto de cambiar
[Música]
una nueva potencia petrolífera todo
apunta a que guayana está a punto de
ingresar en el club de las potencias
petroleras de momento esta pequeña
república de poco más de 750 mil
habitantes ya ha conseguido captar la
atención y sobre todo los dólares de
multinacionales tan importantes como
exxonmobil o lages corporation
de hecho tras varios años de
exploraciones en la zona el pasado 13 de
enero de 2017 estos dos titanes de la
industria del petróleo anunciaron el
descubrimiento del que creen puede ser
uno de los mayores yacimientos de
petróleo y gas descubierto en décadas
los pozos se han encontrado en aguas
profundas en el manto marino bajo las
aguas costeras de guyana y las primeras
estimaciones ojo barajan que la cantidad
de petróleo que se puede explotar no es
inferior a los cuatro mil millones de
barriles de petróleo y no son pocos los
expertos que afirman que la cantidad
puede ser muy superior es decir todo
apunta a que en el peor de los casos
este pequeño país alberga una inmensa
fortuna
[Música]
pero cuanto supone realmente todo esto
teniendo en cuenta el precio actual del
petróleo hablamos de más de 200 mil
millones de dólares es decir dejando a
un lado el gas natural y otros muchos
recursos sólo el petróleo le reportaría
a guyana una riqueza equivalente a un
cuarto de millón de dólares por
habitante e insisto las reservas de
petróleo podrían ser incluso mucho
mayores
es verdad explotar petróleo no es gratis
y desde luego se requieren inversiones
enormes pero precisamente estas podrían
suponer el primer paso de una nueva
época de enorme prosperidad para guayana
tan sólo las dos compañías de petróleo
que hemos mencionado antes
exxonmobil y hess se han comprometido a
invertir en guyana 900 millones de
dólares anuales durante los próximos
años y el gobierno quiere hacer lo
propio la idea es poder empezar a
exportar petróleo en 2020 vamos que
guayana podría estar a las puertas del
mayor proceso de crecimiento y
desarrollo de toda la historia de
sudamérica
si muriera podría llegar a convertirse
en ese país en el que piensas cuando no
tienes trabajo y te dices a ti mismo
quiero cambiar de vida quiero tener una
oportunidad
guyana podría convertirse en la gran
esperanza para muchas personas de
latinoamérica ahora bien antes de que
empecéis a hacer las maletas tenemos que
decir que no va a ser tan fácil el
camino está plagado de dificultades
y conflicto en venezuela
muchas de las exploraciones se están
realizando en aguas que son reclamadas
como propias por venezuela bueno de
hecho no se puede decir que la parte
reclamada por venezuela sea precisamente
pequeña el país de nicolás maduró
considera como propia la región conocida
como guyana esequiba que representa más
del 70% de la superficie total de
guayana
vamos que venezuela reclama casi todo el
país pero por si esto no fuese
suficiente otro 7% del territorio del
país es reclamado por su vecino surinam
es decir que si fuese por sus vecinos a
guyana le quitaban prácticamente hasta
las letras del nombre el caso es que
durante años el conflicto estuvo
congelado probablemente gracias a las
buenas relaciones que el gobierno tenía
con cuba y ya sabéis lo influyente que
es la habana en esta zona del mundo y
también debido a que durante años
venezuela quiso ganarse el apoyo de
organizaciones como el caricom la
comunidad del caribe a la cual pertenece
guyana sí amigos muy llana es
geográficamente un país sudamericano
pero política social y culturalmente es
sobre todo un país caribeño y es que de
hecho guyana era uno de los países
beneficiarios del programa petrocaribe
una iniciativa de hugo chávez que
consistía en proveer de petróleo barato
y en condiciones inmejorables a países
amigos pero todo esto cambió el 11 de
mayo de 2015 cuando el gobierno de
izquierdas del partido progresista del
pueblo perdió
las elecciones contra una coalición
encabezada por el nuevo presidente david
granger un hombre mucho más cercano a
washington y decidido a terminar de una
vez con las reivindicaciones de carácter
en ese momento el conflicto se
descongeló y las declaraciones subieron
mucho de tono
venezuela impone sanciones a guyana hoy
el conflicto está en manos de las
naciones unidas pero está claro que con
independencia de cómo se resuelva y es
que lo hace esta es una importante
amenaza para ese futuro de grandes
alegrías que puede lograr gu jian
conflicto racial otro importante foco de
riesgo se encuentra en un conflicto
racial que recurrentemente salta a la
primera plana de la actualidad de guyana
este país tiene una composición
demográfica relativamente compleja
alrededor de la mitad de la población es
de origen india mientras que
aproximadamente un 40% es de origen
africano
[Música]
es decir hay dos grandes grupos
demográficos que no son precisamente
amigos entre sí de hecho la minoría
negra denuncia que durante años la
mayoría india ha hecho y deshecho a su
antojo obteniendo así privilegios del
gobierno eso ha desencadenado durante
años recurrentes olas de violencia por
fortuna la situación parece haber
mejorado de hecho la coalición que ganó
las últimas elecciones tenía un marcado
carácter multirracial
sin embargo y el riesgo continúa sobre
la mesa en cualquier caso este nuevo
gobierno no sólo supone una gran
oportunidad para superar estos
enfrentamientos de una vez por todas
sino que además fue elegido para luchar
contra la violencia y la corrupción y es
que guyana ojo es uno de los países más
corruptos del mundo según transparencia
internacional si podemos decir que
aparentemente la explotación del
petróleo la lucha contra la corrupción y
la lucha contra delincuencia son los
tres pilares del nuevo gobierno el caso
es que si lo consigue guyana dará mucho
de qué hablar y tal vez pueda aspirar a
convertirse si hacen uso inteligente de
los recursos en el nuevo dubai
latinoamericano la pregunta es lo
veremos en fin y qué pensáis vosotros
será capaz muy llana de extraer todo el
beneficio potencial que tiene el
petróleo descubierto y venezuela- qué
posición deberá adoptar bueno como
siempre espero que este vídeo os haya
resultado interesante si así así darle
al botón de like i suscribiros al canal
por cierto si queréis saber por qué
india puede convertirse en una nueva
superpotencia
clic aquí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]